all right you're on bro what is shaking
thank you for the book can you hear me
all right by the way you're loud and
clear man thanks for grabbing my book
appreciate it
so i really i'm glad to speak to you
you came into my life i want to say in
pretty low point i want to say so my
question is basically
i'm kind of tired of banging low-quality
women
okay and kevin samuel says something and
i hate to bring it up because it's
kind of off topic but he basically
gives the advice to kind of like become
the better version of yourself
and it sounds like you're watching my
stuff
yeah so he he basically saying
that make the better version of yourself
and
find the best person that you can now
i always had a problem sort of like
attracting the seven the eights the
nines and the tens and
i don't really find myself i don't know
up to you your opinion i don't really
find myself really bad looking
i just find myself being short that's an
issue
how tall are you look what's your high
five okay so
i got a friend that's the same height as
you man i i grew up in
you know within my 20s and 30s we were
roommates for three years the guy
the guy was a chat we used to call him
pocket hercules man
because he was a little guy but but he
was always jacked and looked good and he
had like
you know the skin and the hair and like
he had everything down pat
he looks max everywhere else that he
could because he knew that he couldn't
do anything with the height so that's
that's one of the things that you got to
do when you're a shorter man um
how old are you i'm 28. i know i don't
like it but
i'm 28. all right and um what do you do
for a living and where do you live
so i'm like a fine dining waiter and i
as a side hustle i day trade
um i've been day trading around the same
time that i found
you to sort of like help me sort of
propel
i didn't really go to school so i
kind of used the income that i had that
was surplus
um i was living with my mom so rent my
overhead was pretty cheap
so i saved a whole bunch and every
morning i would wake up two hours and
i've been doing it for
three years now this is the year that
i'm possibly gonna make the most money
i'm
gonna surpass 25k for sure um
in that account next year i'm planning
to
[Music]
open an offshore account that kind of
lets me take a lot more margin
now that i'm a little bit more
experienced and sort of
snowball that that's really what my plan
is and hopefully with enough money i'll
buy myself a property and start doing
real estate as well so you live again in
what part of the world
um i live in the united states
connecticut to be more specific
okay um how much money do you make on an
annual basis roughly
40k annually annually 40k
and that's with your day trading as well
um no
no not with my that's not including i
personally like to
remove that when it comes to that
question just because it's
my skill i believe in but the i know
the kind of profession it brings it's
unstable
so until i see myself doing it like a
lot more consistent having a lot more
green days
um i really don't want to add it to it
but that's 40k
with um waiting tables at a five-star
restaurant
okay and i guess you were off for a bit
during the covered lockdowns too right
so you lost them
yeah yeah so definitely unemployment
definitely helped
um i stopped taking it in august i'm
kind of disgusted that people
are still taking it especially men for
sure what kind of women are you dating
right now i mean you're 28 you're decent
dude um i'm dating a 42 year old single
mom dude
for the last five years and i need
something it's
it's yeah dude and it's it's due to low
confidence man and it's
i really don't want to deal with the
women at work because
that could blow up in your face um my
friends are all in relationships with
beautiful women
i don't want a third wheel anymore and
it's what do you think your problem is
it's not height
i want to say the way because i'm very
smart but i feel like at times when
i'm the spotlight's on me i sort of
don't really articulate myself and it
kind of comes off as unconfident
if i may say so myself okay because i
can speak for hours you know
you'd see me rambling on right now i'm
not getting that vibe from you man i'm
getting the vibe of a well-spoken smart
guy but i mean
we've got looks money status game
gotcha how's your game sucky okay
status um still working on it i don't
have the status yet
okay i'm trying to br i'm literally been
breaking my head over this weekend i'm
just like how do i
put myself in uncomfortable situations
to get the kind of outcomes i want
money and money i think
for someone who's on the path on its
purpose i think i'm doing pretty well
for myself
okay and looks you got looks covered
okay thank you okay i mean like you have
a look you have a style
um so you're missing out on three main
areas right like you want to be
influential right to some degree at 28
okay 40 yeah you should be there closer
money i can tell you 42 000 a year
doesn't cut it for women like women
actually
think that there's like
hundreds of millions of men out there
that are all six feet tall
that makes six figures and they're
hiding in some corner of the world you
know
away from them somehow and they all have
to find them but the
like women have very high expectations
of men
right so at 28 okay fine
but you got to get yourself leveled up
to the next level i mean that's why
you're grabbing low hanging fruit like
40 20
42 year old uh single mom yeah dude and
i'm i'm
kind of tired of what's the goal man
like
you know do you think that you can be
making six figures by the time you're 30
i think i could be making six figures in
the next
year and a half to two years okay so um
good job because
like to give an example a lot of my
friends you know got into day trading
during the whole pandemic
they got up there let's go back to
status
what about waiting tables you know you
can say it's a high-end restaurant you
can say it's a michelin star restaurant
but i mean you're still waiting tables
you're bringing food to people do you
think that status looks good on you for
women
you want to date dime pieces right i
mean that's what you're saying like i'm
getting tired of dating like low
quality women i want to date dime pieces
so
do you think that waiting tables at a
high-end restaurant is good enough for
them
i get to meet a lot of them i just don't
think they want to bang the waiter
though
um boom i i definitely want to this
matters dude that
status matters a lot i've i've got a
client who's a very very successful
trades guy
makes 200 000 a year but technically
he's a plumber
okay he lost out to a junior lawyer
at a law firm probably making 60 or 70
000 a year
if he's lucky because it's one of these
personal injury joints
he lost out to that because that guy
looks like better arm candy
on that girl grab the door go ahead
sorry i got two pit bulls at home so
they tend to act out sometimes um
and i
so i i get what you're saying but so how
do i
i guess my goal is at some point i want
to say in the next three years just to
stop working for someone
okay i really hate blocking into work um
i'm sort of i'm what you call
an unmanageable employee um
meaning i do a hell of a job but i come
in when i want and i clock in what
i clock out when i want usually and
because of like the type of
like the way my clients sort of um
react to me for lack of a better term i
can't i should find better words for
that but
it's i get good reviews so my boss keeps
me around
doesn't matter doesn't matter gotcha
doesn't matter what the reviews say it
doesn't matter if you get 100
tip when you're on the dating
marketplace like when you're in the
suction marketplace and you're out there
putting yourself
out trying to get the dime pieces hey
what does this guy do for a living
they have the choice between a waiter
and
entrepreneur lawyer doctor dentist
engineer scientist you know
women are spoiled for like one of the
things that women do
and at some point you're you're probably
going to go through this uh
experiment some of you guys out there
might have done this already but you
have a female friend maybe friends with
benefits
grab her phone one time and see how she
enters the names of men
in her phone as contacts it's going to
be edgar
waiter it's going to be joe vp of sales
it's going to be rich
entrepreneur it's usually first name and
then what they do for a living
that matters like that's part of the
status component of you getting the
reach that you're looking for you want
the dime pieces
you can't rest on your laurels and even
though you get good reviews and your
boss likes you and people tip you well
you don't look like good arm candy
versus somebody else that might have
higher status
out there so as difficult as it might be
to take this jagged little pill
you're not good enough for dime pieces
okay um i mean i say dime pieces but
really my
i would love to land a cute seven that's
doesn't give me a lot of stress
a a agreeable cute seven is far better
than a ten i can tell you that
yeah you always say that i agree with
you so what are you dating now like uh
like where do you put them on the scale
fives four six
i would say the person i'm dating now
i would give her a four or five
yeah dude like i said man it's it was
it was more because this is what
happened to me
give me give me just one second all
right
sorry about that i'm back now so this is
what happened to me i mean
like i was i was high school sweethearts
were really what
really set me to just become very black
pill for like
three years i want to say i didn't start
trying to date till the age of 21.
um she left me for another woman so that
definitely
hit like uh it hit me like i hit my
confidence
and i didn't want to get back out there
so
my relationship muscles sort of
atrophied
and i started
just using dating apps and
really just started avoiding women my
age because of the the amount of
requirements that they have
so i want like i just i mean you open
with
i'm i'm dealing with low quality women
that are exhausted that i'm not
interested in so if you
want to know so if you want to level up
and you want to get the better quality
ones you're going to have to
like like is going to attract like in
that sense right
yeah right so i mean if you want to open
up your opportunities and get
more attractive women that you know
lets you be the uh selector in
that component in that relationship you
need to be spoiled for choice and the
only way that you're going to be in that
position
is if you become a better version of
what you are today
make more money muscles are important of
course the optics of
of of healthy you're not fat right like
i don't see a lot of fat on your face
i'm saying that you're not that guy
um but i do have like
noodle arms basically so i'm muscles are
important broad shoulders narrow waist
okay status is really important to women
as you get older status becomes more
important like if you have no status in
your
20s but you're a good-looking guy you're
a chad you got some good game no problem
but if you're 40 50 you're gonna have to
have something to show for yourself so
just
you know just keep that in mind as you
go as well right gotcha
those are the main things i mean like
you're aware of it you know that
it's a problem you don't want to deal
with the problem so
and again i'm not saying do this so that
so that you're putting women up on a
pedestal so that it's all about getting
dug girls
this is about opening up opportunities
for you this is about opening up doors
for you this is
allowing you to be the selector so that
you can get better results out of life
and say no to low quality say no to
problems
and it eventually will put you in a
position of anti-fragility where
stress comes at you from different
directions and it just bounces off you
it's like you know
it's like your rubber everything that
hits you bounces off you sort of thing
and that's something that you have to
aspire to become
later on in your life in the next decade
or so you got lots of runway ahead of
you
it's a good question to ask you're a
good starting place but now it's time to
do the work
a lot of guys and i've covered this
before and probably
two or three episodes back the red pill
they sit around
they watch content they go from channel
to channel sometimes they
look for drama get on the get on the
soccer pitch you know
get on the pitch and try to score some
goals get on the ice try to shoot you
know for the net
just get on the game floor and start
playing it
beyond just like the basics of messing
with the 42 year old single mom
yeah um just a question um i know it's
a guy like you who possibly has a lot of
like
um high high value
connections i want to say um do you have
any day trading friends
i'm not big on day trading it's not my
thing got you but you are
and i'll be honest with you like i have
a lot of friends that
make great money they didn't make it off
get rich quick schemes day trading stuff
like that it's
mostly from running businesses and then
investing
from the profits of that into
either investments real estate crypto
you know you can go down the list i
don't know a lot of guys that have made
vast fortunes
by day trading anything gotcha
so just be really careful with that like
a lot of guys look for the
get rich quick sort of schemes and
i'm more of the get rich like as quick
as you can but
do it on a schedule that's that's
sustainable
if that makes sense yeah okay
all right so that i mean i mean real
estate's the goal but
i'm not just i'm not going to be able to
do it with 40k a year yeah don't
don't don't focus too much on getting
dying pieces right now like focus on
yourself
okay like you know what you need to do
you know what areas that you're
deficient in
level those up you know like at 28 years
old you shouldn't be putting your arm
out and going like hey look you know
i've
i got a noodle here right you should be
jacked
gotcha you know your body's working
properly you don't need anything aside
from diet health and exercise
so get on that grind get on that purpose
don't make any excuses for yourself
don't rest on lazy laurels like hey my
boss likes me or i get good reviews who
cares
who cares okay thank you all right thank
you for speaking with me man all right
brother peace
take care
you